you're welcome to this video was owned
final starting in about um 10 seconds
five seconds and let's see what's
happening I plague yesterday evening but
I didn't record it I only joined after
15 minutes so I was very very late and
um yeah I was that flat place at some
point okay so will not see what do what
happens yeah this guy is always playing
this age five age four and stuff yeah
it's and of course just bad but it's a
matter of time in in bullet chest he's
playing all this nonsense very quickly
so how to continue it's not so easy
don't think you can open up the FL I
want to go Roxy for to air for my idea
be sure before was my idea it's not yeah
but it's not winning or anything
now you can maybe take p3 and it's not
clear what the answer is ok didn't do
that maybe I can go night at five
because rookie a teaser is made
the ADA's hanging with the mate even
almost
ok
yeah well what can you do it was
terribly long and bad game what can you
do ah come on
hmm I want the game it doesn't work if
edward EDD gates
ah come on this is bad i need the game
here there are people who have played
three games and I simply don't get one
I had this the Sun this little window
where accidentally pressed pause and
that I closed it I'm is my Tony Tony
paused for some reason and if it is how
do how do I get back hmm yeah probably
this is what happened to me like I
clicked I clicked the side I close this
window ah there it is okay so it's not
the tournaments for that I don't get a
game yeah again i'm gifting stuff
unwillingly time
yeah this is a tricky line with Bishop
g5 let's see how we react Bishop g5 or
some can be a problem yeah I can take
here exactly ya know I can take here and
win the Queen yo so one what are the
problems
yeah I'm just up material lots of
material what is it degree for two
pieces
No
hmm ok we need even more stuff ok it's
up here so g 7 i'd be 7i hiding
okay so nothing nothing bad I'll be
happy no la thurs draw office okay this
is really a ultra risky but sometimes
really gives those quick wins that you
need I can do like him yeah okay I was
he going for 94 I just thought i would
blunt at something but I didn't maybe I
did I didn't look didn't think about
that move okay I need to go here Bishop
g5 from okay Bishop t5 I actually can
play Knight f6 which is a good move 25 i
tick you might take here in each other
let's cover this let's gather this
before it takes it now if I have a
couple of couple of like just moves now
now this is actually quite nice for like
five will will fall then it's a very
very active position
now I've got Knight f3 amongst others
look H 5g have it's my idea yeah I'd
like to to block his whole position this
is nice to F form yeah okay let's just
take this pawn yes but I'm controlling
this quite often
hmm well I take it c4 even
okay it's the easiest I think what I
what I just did d force always almost
made ya this is awfully long again this
came and for a very long time it's
totally pointless
okay they are more 20 30 points short
yeah this helps no I really wonder what
works what's do they what's the big idea
at the end always offering those drawers
I don't accept something
No ok so let us quickly open up open up
here the gphone yeah he's so very hard
behind in terms of any any threats or
counter play maybe e5 takes Quincy
father looks like a good way to go yeah
ok let's win the Queen that's easy of
course not resign
k second please five five out of five
yeah some way i would okay I I know a
couple of minutes i just lost you to do
the same pause
now this is nice I've got a probably
Knight to f5 and quickly and I want to
go a four because I want to make sure
that I I stay on on this diagonal this
is just a very nice diagonal to be on ok
I'll go g 5 h 4 and so on this is not
only gaming space but also helping with
jihad to prevent him and playing d5 Wow
hmm yeah I'm not sure many ways to to
play this
his first taking if I go if I go Queen
f6 this winning material that should we
should i limit Irian actually kod I've
got this check securing securing my own
material and I can take care
yeah it's just an extra piece only
slight issue aside the time I spend a
bit of time to get to that
25 seconds sounds are not great
mmm I should have gone to eat you this
was really bad I got them I'm such an
idiot sometimes
yeah you've lost some time I don't know
what happened here in five four you move
let's gamble I can make here can play g5
it's not that's not working please not
not so easy
okay and I even have some extra material
know mdf file we should geforce a big
threat yeah this is nice they are coming
a threat to take and just go clean edge
form intending you for now okay this
should be enough made on h2 and the
Queen some too insane so nine points
short this guy actually lost lost sons
game
yes Queen pawn opening is how he does
take it it's always a bit tricky to take
the pony forward he didn't avoid it then
yeah this this should be in about equal
this Punisher I have a slight structural
advantage but it's it's really really
very little I've got the better bishop
oh no it's get serious it's got to troll
now to a post on the default yeah but
six is saying
so let's just cover this I want to
ideally I want to get the Queen to d5
yeah and now 37 f7a some good role
Bishop age 6 cm that's the coolest rook
GA to Queen h5 year stir is the most
efficient way else double check all
right
okay five cannot go fi fi this is really
really bad I mean sometimes it's good
for a quick win but it's very very risky
yeah what I'm going to do is play g5 no
g5g for this is actually a valid idea if
he cancels quickly short to short
castles quickly and has played h3 then
this g5 stuff is really an option Wow
now I'm really meeting him I don't see
how oh you should defend this Knight to
f4 g8 yahoo g8 and queen h4 check made
now come on not let the clock run down
with maiden to move now ok ok 9 of 9
p.m. mark arnold and i don't think
that's the mark arnold he's the GM now
or some bad quick could be i mean you
never know
and also these guys from the US of
course not I Sullinger all lon I'll o
the owl aunt islands well that is okay
or we have been only here okay I'll push
with that form if you insist I should
have gone here now that I think of it
Bishop erm had a good poor good place on
c4 actually at least that i was playing
quickly okay now i get rid of this this
bishop and down also yeah okay let's
grab the power so what no I want I want
the knight on d4 but there's no rush in
doing that I can just prepare that 92 to
d4 okay pressing d for now be four and
96 one night c 6-r knight c6 is also
good I want this bishop this bishop must
must play that's a check clip ok ok I
white take that
rook e7 should be a pretty strong Oh
Bishop t5 was even stronger ok that's
enough that that was not gonna the u.s.
GM let's play a normal line here ok not
sure maybe you can take here answer I
can actually take on I could have taken
them yeah this is a point but he's got a
very very bad porn structure and I have
some active ideas which should be seven
the bonus of course also hanging on um
on b2k let's activate quickly here okie
8 and rook takes you five
ok this is ok equal material but he's
got the weaknesses on III of course I'm
better developed ok her up this
ok ok ok I've got a good control over
this position his son he's got little
like two possibilities
I'm sure just want to push the pause
here
that's funny funny maneuvers to go here
okay let's uh let's just gain more space
even to hear anything
hmm look 5 30 35 40 now let's go here
spider Roxy to preventing and yeah norm
no I'm coming here with the with my
thing
now have three I want to get get close
to his kingdom trying for making attack
did I get the two pawns no the parts are
rolling they should just promote if i'm
not mistaken age 3g2 it's a bit much
okay one no three points behind Baba
Yaga is doing a good job he's got even a
higher average another knife it's very
very high rated every one to two
something's really high yeah the
budapest i played this this rare line
but it's a it's a pretty good choice but
always it's sufficient for for a small
advantage and you can play it without
knowing any any bugger theory
okay so it just has a very weak phone
and I don't really see how is protecting
it guy wants to go to to be seven
probably now I just try to control the
position don't need to to Russia
I don't mind an endgame of course he's
now in nine this in spin I look at fate
this whole silly no but I have fun I
have an active King is he still worse
I can try to go all the way to to the
a64
look at for now oh god I managed really
to screw this up I don't believe it ok
it's nothing it's nothing terrible I
didn't plan this had to be four of
course ah I'm really playing this badly
there's no way to play for a win here
are you declining a draw then you repeat
him to become okay yeah should have won
this of course was a very good very good
endgame at the at the beginning but i
played this really badly
yeah we've got an English opening here
and a bit of a look so similar to
Hedgehog sometimes you can really do
those slightly wacky attacks and I'm
trying and drawing for once okay before
maybe just him
Wow so where'd you go now c2 hmm ok
let's just retreat yeah at some point
you need to nine isn't a thought he
needs to cover your phone
I cannot truly I can go here man really
I'm really blind or what it takes I can
just go to e3 and I'm asking myself I
have some good square for this Pete
nonsense radium you know my default sir
hanging out our wallet okay maybe I can
fight for the square on c5 let's keep it
simple here oh crap I gotta grab the
spoon enough for two pawns and the good
position
no yeah it's closed about 20 points
behind I don't I don't really want to
play any of those wacky gambits know he
wants I got yeah this should be some
some some compensation
so how to how to open up the position 94
probably you have promised to have F
form and I need I need FL oh yeah not so
whatever I must open up the position now
I cannot wait all day threatening Bishop
deform
come on I just want to give this check
here this is rook age five I made okay
there once in a while you need to
develop okay so yeah these handles you'd
only get to get good opposition almost
all of them have got to learn something
22 yeah this is a funny funny again bed
of course but it's it's quite dangerous
night to d3 ok so just develop and I
want to want to keep the night and if i
take on d5 here you can play Queen two
can play the Queen oh ah ok it's not
it's not so not so terrible I get it I
get it back with very very decent
compensation no I'm not even worse iam I
really have compensation for the porn
maybe here
this didn't help clean cool too d 3 i'd
like to play maybe you can take it here
doesn't account for them it will make
some progress night III SS not go down
maybe get some space and try for h for
taking it for now night f4 or this one
is still not working maybe Knight f6
Queen d5 something like that Nyjah for
now yeah it's it's all those those
little threats but term so it's very
annoying in the long run
yeah tonight f3 you cannot take them I
don't want to exchange rogue suffer I
mean the exchange exchange material
Queens his king is still still very weak
want to try to to play for made e6 I
play would be three will be three anyway
maybe no here threatening Wookiee to
insides just a chicken can Queen f8 and
no is govno check know that covered okay
yeah I'm still slow behind and I'm
winning almost all games but maybe the
Smith Moroccan can help
No
now come on we go then please need to
win quickly here
hmm no this some stuff hanging already
Queen and night night before I go queen
bee three man did Sam it's a pin and win
situation okay cuz it's still hanging
damn this will be a very very big attack
with castles and rocky 197 26 cm
the 94 probably quindi 894 what can I
Akane on 95 instantly yeah 95 is even
better yeah maybe he's just castling or
something
you take it
yeah this probably wasn't working effect
I'm simply not winning cook enough I
can't believe it maybe I'm just a bit
too too rusty for those tournaments I
mean in terms of really winning quickly
get us this line is really terrible for
what yeah okay take the rook I'll take
it if you are insisting to give me a
look I'll take it yep this is the young
Liam slight idea in this position I take
it I can actually just take it
for do a six Tuesday six
94 or what me I can take I can take with
the bishop would be five yeah probably i
had to add some more precise way to play
it i can take up with this now it
doesn't help this guy is still 30 points
that he's got four more games played
yeah very composition like a starter
quality probably okay now no maybe I
have little something
no no ok let's activate
this is crude but it's it is dangerous I
just go to the edge phone ah 25 yeah
such a cheap trick iana the only need a
couple of seconds to spot it okay yeah
this is a bit silly I had it really this
was a very very good position before it
was very hard for him to even know
prevent me from meeting him on the edge
phone
so queen age 16 the way is playing it
down it doesn't really matter it seems
threatening Luke h5 and Luke g6 rook g6
that's probably enough this is even
matter okay come on seven minutes left
just just two quick ones the other
sriman is always a good bet for quick
win you can also of course use quickly
once in a while but this is already a
very good good line so it's simply a an
excellent structure
okay i can go here it's not not a big
deal hmm ok exchange coins whatever he
can take care of it I get Queens the
Queen exchange would actually overlook
just that I have got the night the night
dear so really a calm down now so stupid
I thought I we need for and of course
this is not the case
how to i can can get them get b5 stuff
just take it what is happening to me
somethin bad I don't know 96 so what
this is
now let's just activate pieces it's not
that was so bad he's got those pieces
and h4 especially on each phone and this
is not doing much this look is also
quite weird let's just take it okay yeah
I can take now here you have a better
better take
look III or something
got ruka know this has made him okay
still in second place hey I won't
manager needs to once and I don't get
them yeah of course this is not exactly
the way to play for a very quick win but
at least it's an all those notices this
is no actually possible to play for a
quick win
g5 coming yeah okay I need to I need to
be quick here
No
now it was a bit of a gamble if he takes
with the point it's not so Cleavon this
is this is the problem really Queen age
7 and I now look G sixth coming
ok
King King there this route g8 made next
move its Queen h7 made this mess was
okay maybe I now win and the other guy
loses for a change or something that's
unnatural and now I get it to four
player great yep this this is the
problem the only way is to play such
stuff and hope for a very quick win yeah
it's not bad for me so it's very similar
to see no no yeah it's excellent for
black but and you did a quick win this
is a problem
97 Elsa threatening this is probably not
working but I need to need to do to win
here quickly everything else ok this is
so what it's over second place yeah it's
not bad but also not not really what I
was hoping for 13 points short of first
place alright so I'm just a couple of
points short but it wasn't really enough
yeah thanks for watching I hope you
liked it anyway and yeah talk to you
soon